duck chess has become popular I'm going  to jump to our first Community question  from two of them our own chesscom trim  asks whether you've played duck chess  yet and then chess weeb and chat wanted  to ask whether whether you're going to  be playing in a duck Chess Championship  so have you played duck chess and would  you want to become the first ever World  duck chess champion  I haven't played duck chess but I I  watched  Hammer stream a little bit of duck chest  the other day I thought uh okay let me  try to sit through one game of this  um my first impression was uh  um was like Whoever thought of duck  chess just thought how can I  take chess and make it  just uh really boring uh it seems that  the games are just a lot  a lot slower it's harder to Checkmate uh  I guess there are some other weird  tactics but I just I just found it uh  incredibly boring but I know that other  people like it so that's that's very